[Musique]
première séance plénière pour la
nouvelle mandature présidé par cyril
melchior une séance consacrée aux
orientations budgétaires pour l'année
les élus renouvelle l'engagement de la
collectivité pour la solidarité sociale
l'épanouissement humain le développement
territorial et l'intelligence
institutionnels le président rappelle
l'application dès cette année du pacte
de solidarité territoriale
c'est extrêmement important ce pacte sur
l'égalité territoriale va seule version
115 millions sur trois ans 25 millions
par an et ce pacte va nous permettre des
pansements d'accompagner les 24 communes
dans leur politique de proximité
d'équipements de proximité et il y aura
un volet social bien sûr parce que je
veux le département travaille avec les
ccas des communes pour répondre aux
attentes des familles les plus en
difficulté dans le domaine social le
département également rappelé son
soutien au développement du monde
agricole réunionnais à l'aménagement des
routes départementales avec un budget
consacré à la suppression des radiés
malgré un contexte économique difficile
la collectivité maintient ses efforts
financiers dans les dispositifs
d'accompagnement auprès de la population
réunionnaise
le département se serrera la ceinture et
il fera en sorte que dans les trois
années à venir
cette priorité réunionnaise reste ne
sera pas l'essai d'ondées sera pas les
éléments d'accompagnement de la famille
de la personne de l'enfant de la maman
et et d'une grand moun
on restera justement sur ce projet une
première séance plénière qui a salué la
présence d'une nouvelle conseillère
départementale en remplacement de
viviane mal et qui occupe désormais
pleinement son poste de sénatrice
de prendre la continuité du travail de
ma collègue qui est maintenant sénatrice
en l'occurrence viviane j'espère de tout
mon coeur le mener à bien pour la
population
les conseillers départementaux ou tenu à
rendre hommage aux treize années de
présidence de nassimah dindar son
portrait désormais affichée dans
l'hémicycle aux côtés des dix premiers
présidents du département
c'est à la fois professionnelle à la
fois symbolique et à la fois amicales
dans le sens de l'amitié
la vraie amitié c'est un moment
important pour la maîtrise de ses
dépenses et la présentation d'un budget
équilibré
le département de la réunion a été
sélectionné parmi douze collectivités
test au niveau national pour signer en
2018 un pacte de confiance avec l'état
[Musique]